the mendez family are doing chores
around their home
the water for the meal they're having
this evening arrived directly to their
home thanks to a community water project
funded in part by the united states
agency for international aid and
development
or usaid running water has been a
life-changing
upgrade for the family
life has changed because we now have
water we used to have to go all the way
down to the hill to collect it
but all thanks to god we now have our
own water
across guatemala impoverished
communities have received billions of
dollars in aid from the united states
over the years
money aimed at improving economic
conditions and discouraging migration
from the country
despite these efforts poverty has only
worsened
jonathan an expert on economic
development says the solution isn't as
simple as pouring more money at the
problem
the truth is the united states is the
country that provides the most support
to guatemala and the three countries of
northern central america
the problem is that no international
cooperation is going to substitute the
need to establish functional public
institutions for the development of
democracy
that is a task that is ultimately up to
the guatemalan government
though some critics argue that
international aid has fallen short of
creating true economic stability
it doesn't mean that development
projects have failed
from this central water tank 95 percent
of homes
in five different indigenous communities
now have access to clean water
the hope of development workers is that
projects like these can be replicated
across all of guatemala
in the village of el tisape community
leaders say the key to making
international development projects like
these successful
is to make them sustainable
we've received training on
sustainability by usaid so that people
can be more autonomous because one day
the donors will leave our community
but now we know how to maintain a
healthy water supply
u.s president joe biden has pledged four
billion dollars to the governments of
guatemala honduras and el salvador to
expand on programs like the the sati
community water project
here the positive impact the program is
having on the health and livelihoods of
residents is clear
what's uncertain is if the biden
strategy will succeed
where previous plans have fallen short
and create the economic conditions
necessary
for central america's poorest families
to truly thrive
now we've known for some time that the
biden plan
to curb migration from central america
is a departure from the
strategies and policies of his
predecessor donald trump now on the one
hand
this visit by u.s vice president kamala
harris to guatemala does represent
a sort of re-establishing of that
relationship between the united states
and the governments of central america
under the guise
of multilateralism but what we're
hearing overwhelmingly from development
experts
here in guatemala specifically is that
ultimately it is up to the guatemalan
government
to make sure that foreign aid isn't lost
to corruption to make sure
that that government that democratic
institutionality doesn't lose
its legitimacy and without that no
amount of foreign aid is going to solve
the problems
that are forcing people in in central
america specifically countries like
guatemala
honduras and el salvador to risk their
lives fleeing north toward the united
states
got it okay thank you so much emmanuel
rappolo for that reporting from the
guatemala
border uh let's um well talks
in fact are expected to focus on the
so-called northern triangle countries in
central america those are guatemala
honduras and el salvador
so most people in the region either live
in poverty or they work in the informal
sector leaving them without support or
protections
the coronavirus pandemic has made their
situation even worse
many are now fleeing to escape crime and
corruption
el salvador and honduras have the
highest homicide rates in the world
and in 2014 the obama administration
gave 750 million dollars to address the
root causes of migration in the northern
triangle in 2019 that aid was frozen by
donald trump
and now president joe biden wants to
increase it to four billion dollars
let's now speak to william lawrence
who's a professor of international
relations at the american university
he's joining us from washington thanks
for your time with us
on al jazeera so um kamala harris's
press secretary
has said that she is picking up where
the then
vice president joe biden left off when
he himself worked
on this portfolio under the obama
administration but
how do you think this time is this time
in fact going to be different than the
attempts by
previous u.s administrations and what's
your sense of what we can actually
expect from this trip
well let me say that these problems are
long-term structural problems that take
years to solve uh but it's much better
to do something as your excellent report
indicated than to not do something
uh and so it's great that kamel harris
and
president biden have negotiated this new
package
of assistance including another 300
million dollars for hurricane relief and
drought relief
uh and then a whole suite of new
cooperative packages and there'll be
several
announcements related to that over the
coming days because
you have to simultaneously both deal
with the border issues where there's
been some improvements despite the surge
and the systemic issues that send so
many migrants headed for the border
uh and that's the right approach and
finally getting that reestablished
in terms of kamala harris she's had some
friction
uh with the president of guatemala he
did some interviews over the weekend in
which she was critical of
some of her approaches including her
focus on corruption which is of course
connected to the development issue
um but this is kamala harris uh
developing with foreign policy chops
it's a priority of the byte
administration
to allow her to have some some lead on
foreign policy issues
in preparation for 2028 or 2024
elections
and so far so good she's she's uh you
know doing all the right things saying
all the right things and getting some
diplomatic practice it's very hard
sometimes for
for politicians to get used to the idea
that sometimes in diplomacy you have to
be
publicly conciliatory and privately
tough uh and that's something that
she'll be practicing during this trip
ray but how would you define success of
this trip when it will obviously take
some time
to see the results of this diplomacy by
kamala harris and the investment that
she's putting forward
so for example the president of
guatemala wants uh to start
extradition of narco-traffickers and
other criminals to u.s
courts that's something they can have an
announcement on new law enforcement and
judicial cooperation
which hasn't been announced that's
something they can cooperate on
the president guatemala sees his primary
issues is narco traffickers and their
deletorious effects on guatemala
honduras and el salvador something we
haven't really done that well on
so on that let's say law enforcement and
security side of the coin
is where we've had the least progress uh
whereas
on the pure economic and developmental
side the pandemic and the vaccine
things related to climate change drought
we've had much more progress but on the
law enforcement side
i think is where they could have the
most important gains going forward
look i mean republicans over in the u.s
are saying that the administration needs
to do much more to stem the flow of
migrants and in fact april
saw a pretty high numbers in fact record
numbers of migrants trying to come
cross over into the u.s so how much
political pressure
is the administration under and kamala
harris herself
to stem the flow of migrants
tremendous political pressure and the
republicans are right about the issue
even if they're politicizing it often in
unfair ways
uh but what happened is that the obama
administration
uh implemented a humane policy that said
basically children at the border
are going to be treated humanely and
integrated into
u.s assistance and you and into their
families a lot of them have relatives
united states
and that's what created the surge as the
president of guatemala said
the coyotes were recruiting literally
the day the policy was announced
so the u.s has to do a much better job
at the border particularly
in regards to to how children are
treated
and to that end the us i think has run
now 30
000 advertisements in the northern
triangle countries to try to stem the
flow
uh it's trying to be clearer on which
children will be repeated back towards
those countries into mexico and it's
trying to reduce the flows but right now
we've had this tremendous surge
and it's you know it's really nobody's
fault it's under international law you
have to treat children humanely
as we saw recently between morocco and
spain i mean you really have to separate
out the children but that creates
these new supply let's say migration
issues that have to be dealt with
in an intelligent way and a lot of
that's about as you've said
economic development and proper
messaging all right thank you so much
for speaking to us from washington dc
william lawrence